dass die oppositionellen verurteilt
werden dient dem Ziel dass dieser Unmut
den es ja gibt über der den ja auch
gesprochen worden ist hier heute in
dieser Sendung dass der sich nicht
kanalisieren kann das ist keine Anführer
gibt und Wladimir karamosa war der
letzte der noch in Freiheit war und
deswegen ist er jetzt verurteilt worden
russland hat Potenzial für eine
demokratische Entwicklung also man
sollte nicht den Glauben die sagen also
wenn Putin nicht mehr da wäre dann würde
es noch schlimmer kommen es gibt viele
Menschen die ein anderes Russland wollen
und wir können hoffen dass die eines
Tages die Chance dazu haben werden was
ist jetzt als nächsten Schritt braucht
ist das Russland diesen imperialen
Angriffskrieg den Putin begonnen hat
klar verliert dass er nicht zusätzliches
Land gewinnt oder irgendwie ermutigt
wird auf diese Art und Weise weiter zu
machen das ist glaube ich das wichtigste
was passieren muss damit auch in
Russland dann eine positive Entwicklung
irgendwann mal eine Chance hat
wir sprechen jetzt aktuell definitiv
nicht von einer Demokratie aber von was
sprechen wir von einer Diktatur von
einem autoritären Staat wie würden sie
es bezeichnen
man muss glaube ich konzentrieren dass
Putins autoritäres Regime
sich immer weiter in Richtung einer
Diktatur entwickelt hat und das mit
Beginn des Krieges in dem ja nicht nur
Leute verurteilt werden jetzt weil zum
Beispiel die Tochter ein Bild gemalt hat
oder weil sie mit einem weißen Blatt
Papier demonstrieren im Laufe dieses
Krieges ja ständig auch Gesetze
verschärft werden harte Strafen
ausgesprochen werden können alles
mögliche bestraft werden kann also diese
Diktatur wandelt sich zu einem
totalitären Regime
ist ein stalilismus Vergleich wie wir
ihn ja mitunter hören aus ihrer Sicht
angebracht
Putin selbst sorgt doch für den
stalinismusvergleich mit dieser
Ideologie die er aus dem Großen
Vaterländischen Krieg gemacht hat der ja
der Sowjetunion gehört den er aber für
Russland vereinnahmt und mit diesem Kult
das ist sogar gut ist wenn viele
Menschen in einem Krieg fallen weil das
zeigt wie ernst man es meint also da
sind doch stalinsche Elemente und Putin
selbst hat doch dafür gesorgt dass
volgrad für einen Tag wieder in
Stalingrad umbenannt wurde also er
zeichnet ganz gezielt diese Parallelen
zu Stalin
hier gibt es eine Frage die gebe ich
jetzt einfach mal an sie weiters wenn
Odendahl fragt über Facebook noch mal zu
dieser online einen Berufung die wir
gerade thematisiert haben ist das nicht
aus Putins Sicht gefährlich das
Informationen über die Truppenstärke
abgefangen werden können Sie das
irgendwie einschätzen bei dieser
online-berufung geht es ja nicht um
Informationen über die Truppenstärke es
geht nur darum dass die Menschen die
diese einberufungsbescheide kriegen als
zugestellt betrachtet werden können auch
wenn man sie nicht persönlich
angetroffen hat oder sie irgendwo
physisch getroffen hat und ihnen diese
Dinge überreichen konnte damit versucht
man
das Ausweichen zu erschweren aber
Informationen über die Stärke der
russischen Armee kann man da nicht
ableiten die Russen sind ja nicht dumm
die Russen informieren sich auch und die
Nutzung zum Beispiel von vpn-netzwerken
ist sehr stark gestiegen in den letzten
Monaten während dieses Krieges die
Russen wissen ja dass sehr viele
Soldaten fallen dass das unattraktiv ist
so dieser Truppe zu gehen und das
Russland auch nichts erreicht in diesem
Krieg und das auch eine ukrainische
Gegend Offensive kommen wird also es ist
eher empfindlichen Zeichen der Schwäche
und der Verzweiflung wenn man jetzt all
diese Maßnahmen ergreift und irgendwie
noch Leute dazu zu bewegen in die
russische Armee zu kommen weil sie das
gerade ansprechen hier fragt über
Youtube jemand wie würde sich an
russischer ruckzuck jetzt springen hier
die Kommentare weg und es kommen so
viele nach dass der den ich jetzt an Sie
weitergeben wollte schon wieder weg ist
da ist er wie würde sich ein russischer
Rückzug bei einer erfolgreichen
ukrainischen Frühlingsoffensive in
Russland innenpolitisch auswirken weil
sie das gerade angesprochen haben
die Russen wissen auch jetzt schon dass
dieser Angriffskrieg von Putin dass der
kein großer Erfolg ist da kann die
Propaganda noch so viel
Tönen das ist allen klar man sollte auf
jeden Fall nicht den Fehler machen zu
denken wenn Russland die Ukraine
verlassen muss wenn es also kein Land
dazu gewinnt durch diesen imperialen
Angriffskrieg dann wäre das irgendeine
existenzielle Bedrohung für Russland das
ist die Erzählung die Putin versucht
indem er den Angriffskrieg im Grunde mit
der Verteidigung im Großen
Vaterländischen Krieg gleich setzt das
ist aber falsch wenn Russland in der
Ukraine den Krieg verliert also das
Gebiet wieder verlassen muss dann kann
Russland weiterleben hat vielleicht
sogar eine Chance auf eine bessere
Entwicklung also man sollte sich dann
nicht erzählen lassen dass das für
Russland eine existenzielle Bedrohung
wäre sicherlich wird es Diskussionen
geben im Land und Putin als Person weil
er diesen Krieg angefangen hat und er
persönlich diese Entscheidung getroffen
hat und es wird sicherlich auch breitere
Diskussionen geben unter den russischen
Eliten ob es denn das wert da diese
Dinge diese Dinge zu tun und diesen
Krieg so zu führen aber diese Diskussion
gibt es ja auch jetzt schon in
vielleicht in dieser vorgehaltener Hand
und nicht so sichtbar für uns aber ganz
sicher die sind diese Diskussionen noch
jetzt schon da
lassen Sie uns noch einen Aspekt
beleuchten der in den letzten Wochen und
Monaten veraufsehen gesorgt hat und zwar
die Rolle russischer militärblogger wir
erinnern uns an den Fall des einen der
in St Petersburg einem Anschlag zum
Opfer gefallen ist und der dann auch
beerdigt wurde unter der Teilnahme unter
anderem von Wagner Chef prigoschin und
von anderen ultra-nationalisten die dort
ihre Unterstützung noch mal kundgetan
haben wenn wir uns angucken was die so
äußern dann sehen wir offensichtlich
dürfen die Kritik an der Armee üben
dürfen auch den Krieg thematisieren
wird damit zweierlei Maß gemessen warum
werden Oppositionelle zu 25 Jahren
Straflager verurteilt und militärblogger
dürfen da frei ihre Meinung äußern oder
was steckt da dahinter
es gibt ja berechtigten Grund zur
Annahme dass das gewaltsame Vorgehen
gegen diese militärblogger durchaus vom
russischen Verteidigungsministerium oder
vom russischen Regime ausgehen könnte
insofern ist es vielleicht gar nicht so
dass die sich frei bewegen können
zumindest gibt es da versuche sie
einzuschränken putin ist da glaube ich
mit etwas konfrontiert dass man
bezeichnen könnte als die Geister die
ich rief werde ich heute nicht mehr los
denn er hat sich ja mit diesen extremen
Nationalisten eingelassen hat sich von
ihnen unterstützen lassen aber aus deren
Sicht geht er jetzt nicht weit genug die
wollen so etwas wie einen totalen Krieg
die wollen die Einberufung aller und
etwas viel stärkeres als die sogenannte
spezialoperation und er steht unter
Druck weil er keine militärischen
Erfolge vorzuweisen hat und wird da
ständig korrigiert und verbessert und
von da gibt es immer Ideen wie man denn
jetzt eigentlich militärisch Vorankommen
könnte das ist ganz sicher eine
Bedrohung für Putin und viele dieser
Auseinandersetzungen laufen ja zwischen
dem Verteidigungsministerium und der
Wagner ab manchmal gibt es auch
Absetzungen von bestimmten Generälen
oder Austausch von Personal diese
Konflikte werden ganz sicher jetzt
intensiv weitergehen weil ja die
russische Offensive im Winter keinerlei
Erfolge vorzuweisen hat und Russland
keine militärischen Ziele erreicht hat
man aber damit rechnen muss dass die
Ukraine bei der Gegenoffensive die Sie
vorbereitet die Russen zumindest in
weiten Teilen zurückdrängen wird und
wenn man das dann weiterdenkt und sich
fragt wer Putin denn gefährlich werden
könnte welche Rolle spielt dann
wagner-chef prigoshi
ich glaube dass er in Russland nicht so
eine starke Rolle spielt wie das
manchmal scheint der ist da eher ein
nebenakteur aber es ist natürlich
gefährlich wenn man grundsätzlich
private Militärfirmen hat also im Grunde
Privatarmee es gibt ja mittlerweile
nicht nur die wagnergruppe sondern auch
andere Privatarmeen die aktiv sind und
wenn die
gesetzgeberischen Funktionen oder die
Durchsetzung der Gesetze durch den Staat
in Russland gefährdet ist weil man die
Ordnung nicht mehr aufrecht erhalten
kann weil man zum Beispiel im Krieg zu
viele Leute verloren hat weil man immer
weiter mobilisieren muss wenn man Ärger
hat mit diesem mobil machen dann sind
diese bewaffneten Gruppen natürlich eine
Gefahr für diese innere Ordnung in
Russland aber ich würde Herrin jetzt
auch nicht überschätzen in der Frage wer
wird da Putin gefährlich ist glaube ich
glaube es gibt hinter den Kulissen noch
andere Dinge die da ablaufen aber das
ist wie schon am Hofe des Zaren und
früher im undurchsichtigen Kreml bei den
Kommunisten jetzt auch bei Putin das ist
sehr sehr undurchsichtig und für uns
manchmal nicht so richtig zu verstehen
wer da eigentlich die wichtigen Akteure
sind eine Frage noch eines Users an Sie
Eduard Kundt fragt eine Frage an Herrn
Lange wer wäre eigentlich Putins
Nachfolger meiner Meinung nach käme doch
nur patruschef in Frage
die Frage ist nicht geklärt Putin hat
schon seit langem nachfolgeproblem
deswegen ist er im Grunde verdammt dazu
Präsident zu bleiben und der Übergang
ist nicht geklärt und wenn man sich die
russische Geschichte des letzten
Jahrhunderts oder noch länger anguckt
scheint das ja ein generelles Problem zu
sein dass häufig die Führer der
Kommunistischen Partei oder die Zahlen
sterben und dann nicht klar ist Werder
Nachfolger wird und ich würde in diesem
Fall auch vermuten es würde zunächst mal
eine große Unsicherheit geben und
vielleicht auch Versuche Kollektiv über
die Nationalen Sicherheitsrat oder über
andere Dinge das Land zu führen bis klar
ist wer tatsächlich ein Nachfolger wird
Herr patrochef ist jedenfalls jemand der
sich vor allen Dingen selbst immer
wieder ins Gespräch bringt